[Musique]
vous nous avez émerveillant 40 ans de
carrière à une mobilisation avec votre
nouveau spectacle monsieur tout le monde
quels sont vos nouvelles imitations je
me sens j'ai trouvé une façon de faire
robert charlebois qui s'en vont un peu
vers le jim morrison son influence peut
être qu'on était plus jeune je peux
faire un conception je ferai quelque
chose qui s'approche assez alors il ya
des des nouvelles voies que je peux me
permettre m'étais marc hervieux
[Musique]
parce que je m'imaginais toujours une
marque est revue en chantant de
berceuses pour un petit bébé alors je
suis désolé pour le
technicien de son mais attention
[Applaudissements]
si ça prend ça pour l'endormir que ça
prend pour les réveiller
vous avez toujours le même plaisir malin
ça se voit tout mais depuis tout petit
aussi que j'appelle j'ai réalisé que tu
fais en faisant des imitations ben tu
sais ça fait rire tout le monde autour
d'autres et puis j'ai un frère pays que
j'adore fernand chi chi x et bats c'est
lui justement quand je serai plus jeune
j'ai eu le front du loc'h un tri bird le
petit oiseau dans box bonnet puis les au
lieu de me chatouiller forts comme les
grands frères le fond et maman a décrit
tweedy bug date un peu psy lui pense que
mon tweedy brut assez pour savoir que
bon mad dog vachon est preque mon jean
béliveau est prêt à cma diane dufresne
est qu'avec mon yvan deschênes jaune
avec exact je faisais vous donnez votre
carrière à votre frère
bernard
[Rires]
mais quand tu dois deux enfants de 8 ans
l'espace méhauté meilleur et puis
ça fait
deux
you may justin bieber
justement vos débuts c'était au lundi
des arts vous avez unités l'homme au
saxophone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec des jeux de mots de trompette
clarinette sax tuba en veille dans mes
mains vides en
fait c'est aussi c'est un mélange de
leucate métal en cuillère en bois puis
aussi le son de radiohead et christie
[Musique]
s'est calmé ces deux mélanges d'eau qui
font le
buzz
c'est le bruit 40 ans de carrière vous
en fait à 35 en 1985 vous aviez vingt
deux ans au tonight show avec johnnie
carson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dessus
la saq
et je vais peut-être que je dois vous
révéler ce que l'agent mon agent n'est
pas que refuser une première date du
tonight show
lorsque j'étais à saint prosper de
beauce cette date là alors mon agent ne
voulait pas perdre un client mais ce
dieu et qu'ils n'entreraient labeur
ils ont rappelé qu'un disque il est
disponible et isabella beurre yes alors
moi j'ai déjà plusieurs années après
sinon battre
[Musique]
vous êtes un véritable marathonien la
scène quand même fait du soir après soir
pour garder votre voix intacte parce que
c'est difficile j'imite cette grande
chanteuse notre plus grande chanteuse
céline dion et j'ai la chance d'être de
faire sa première partie en 98 dans le
monde arabe à la fois graviter autour de
certains si tu apprends l'accepter et
puis des ajustements de elle quand elle
termine ses spectacles c'est pas un mot
ces rencontres avant les faits avant
justement par des photos peu après
spectacle
céline a quitté le building c'est fini
et puis ben - près au lieu de parler
comme fois pour pas avec les gens où
aller on va manger quelque chose d'assez
je ne la ferme si je parlais trop fort
il va avoir cette voie lol matin qui va
s'installer aux boys l'autre c'est
comment je fais pour faire des bêtises
ce soir il avait 17 faire un peu c'était
une alive ça fait
on est loin des epa le double en bois de
l'eau au puits alors tout passer la
journée se stresse comme ça ça va c'est
bon pour livrer à tamiser ce soir le
soir même magie c'était cette technique
l'un des jeux les plus techniques céline
noti2 de la firme était juste de
d'attendre le lendemain juste pour faire
un sens que chacun après midi le pitch
un petit des fois un petit jean
géant vert pour
[Musique]
les barreaux ces mêmes problèmes nous
mêmes andré philippe gagnon je n'ai
jamais autant ri pendant une entrevue
beaucoup et merci à toi ça a été très
agréable merci pour tout